we're here with Grand Master Gregory
Cardona Gregory you were the last
qualifier buy rating were you expecting
again an invite not at all not at all i
was very lucky because a couple of
people were disqualified because of
different criteria somebody decline so
for people who are ahead of me so when
Tony send me an email that I mean I said
Tony I'm sure it's mistake but you can
take it away yeah I don't think Tony
would be that cruel but in a way you
represent the last of the old garden
forgive me for saying it that way but
there's no more Benjamin you know you're
Malinsky and Christians in orch here
does that are you carrying the mantle
for the players that have been around
for a little while these change of
generations happen very suddenly and
just turns out I'm the last one but I
hope to stay so obviously my chances in
this particular championship are not
great I am the oldest and the lowest
rated but I'm kind of coming back for a
few years I didn't play too much didn't
study too much but I'm trying to get
back into that so I hope to make the
next one yes you were dominant in the
early 90s and then again in the two
thousand your rating went well over 2700
are we seeing another parabola upward in
your chest i will try from 44 years from
2002 to 2005 i was the number one rated
player in the country but then it's
basically almost like just just playing
was on the back of my mind I was
teaching a lot i was playing poker all
kind of things but i'll try to do
another comeback
and even though you're not one of the
higher rated players here is it your
goal to still win your first arrest
championship no I don't have this goal
obviously it's my kind of secret holes
not secret anymore I guess but I'll try
to do my best well I know a lot of
people are hoping that you finally get
one but we wish you well in your quest
thank you very much yeah thanks very
thank you